welcome to this first session
of the omics logic data science program
in today's session our team will be
sharing
information examples and an overview of
omics logic training resources designed
for
anyone to learn data science for
biomedical data
as seen in application to projects
sourced from
current topics in biomedical research
in this one month program we will
combine
online sessions like we're having today
self-guided study materials and
practical
assignments for an immersive experience
that has proven to be effective in our
well-known and respected omics logic
programs
to begin with let me introduce you to
the resources that we will be utilizing
in this program the first resource
is our educational platform i am putting
the link to the educational platform
in the chat box
in this platform you will find
introductory courses to projects which
will serve as a step-by-step guide
and will help you as a springboard into
the world of
bioinformatics
our next platform is a powerful tool
to help anyone perform ngs data
analysis we have created a platform that
has
over 30 different pipelines
and enables anyone with a computer and
an internet connection
to perform complex bioinformatics
analysis by running bioinformatics
pipelines
in the cloud and
i will be giving you an overview of this
platforms
very shortly
our third platform is the code omics
logic
which offers practical coding
assignments to
help you understand the
r and python code elements that will be
part of
any data science project you end up
working on in the future
we have a question here from ash team
and ashley
we will be answering your question very
very shortly
and ila will be addressing them in a
while
but before we can answer your questions
let me
take you to the different resources and
show you the registration process for
the program
as i just realized that there are a lot
of users who have joined us today
for the first time and may not know how
to register for the data science program
so the edut by info platform
that you see right here and i've also
shared the link again
in the chat box is the first platform as
i explained
which will help you get acquainted with
the different
multi-omics courses so
if you see here under the courses there
are different courses
which are covered one of the main course
that we suggest that everyone take
is the introduction to bioinformatics
so this is a free course and if you are
just joining our platform
for the first time we definitely
recommend you to go ahead
and take this course and if you have
already taken this
course then you know that what this
course talks about it's a very basic
and introduces you to buying for matrix
and this
will serve as the starting point for the
program
and later on we will go on and explore
more courses
now coming to the program registration
a lot of you may have already seen this
program
registration page and in this page
you will have all the details of the
different sessions of the program
what the program is about as you see
today we are here on introduction to
data types and properties that
elia will be talking about very shortly
once i finish this overview and
you must have registered via this form
here
right at the bottom of this page now if
you have not already registered and are
interested in registering
you can still register via the link here
and i will also send out the links in
case that you are not able to
access the chat right now or are
watching from your mobile phone and
cannot register so i can send out
an email to everybody after the session
along with the video recording
that you can access the links easily
so once you're registered for the
program to complete your registration
you need to just go on this page it's
called data science.omixlogic.com
and we have several different options
here
to get registered for the program and
very quickly i'll give you an overview
of what the beginner
intermediate and advanced options mean
the beginner option is perfect for
anybody who is just getting started
in your data science journey and wants
to learn the program this will give you
access to the full program
and all of its resources while the
intermediate program goes a step ahead
and gives you access to a mentor
who would be available to work with you
on a one-on-one session so in the
beginner program
we will have group meetings like we're
having today with everybody
but in the intermediate membership
option
uh you can also request for a one-on-one
meeting with
a mentor who can solve any questions
that you may have
while the advanced option gives you an
additional 30 days to work on your
bioinformatics data science project
and also collaborate with our research
interns who are part
of our community and work with the
mentors on developing the project so
this is recommended for anybody who is
sure that they would want to develop a
project
and needs that amount of time which is
beyond the
next 30 days to work and develop this
project so once you are registered here
you will be finding
all the payment details and if you have
a coupon code you can add that coupon
code and register for the program
abdul has a question why is this program
not free
so although the resources that you see
as well as the time of the mentor
who will be assisting you during this
sessions
cannot be made free at this point of
time
we do hope that we are able to offer
this to the maximum number of people and
hence we are having a free session like
this one today
so thank you again for joining and once
you are registered for the program you
will receive
an email from my end which is marketing
and pine dot bio
so this will enroll you into this
organization page
which is called the omics data science
organization page
now the organization page is
going to be like a classroom where you
can have an
update of all the sessions
and all the events that are there within
this particular program for the next 30
days
so here you see today we are doing the
session one the next session
[Music]
is going to be on 14th january
so the program is a mix of self
learning as well as online uh
sessions and the way we mix it up is
you will be given access to asynchronous
courses
let me pull it up here so these
asynchronous courses you can take them
at any point of time during this one
month period
and they cover different multi-omics
topics and are related to the program
what we will actually do in the sessions
is go beyond the courses like we will
take
sometimes for example we'll take up a
part of this course and explain them
during the sessions
explain the logic of analysis help you
run the pipelines together and explain
what these pipelines mean and
once you are familiar with it you can go
ahead and do more courses
and the reason this exercise has been
designed is to help you
understand first and then apply the same
logic to your
own biofuel matrix problems or
biological questions
and as you see in this
organization page you also have a forum
so for example in the forum here we have
also given you a tutorial
on how to get started with installing rn
python
which is going to be a feature in this
program we are going to be covering
a lot of this and then moving ahead
one thing that all of you must do even
if you're registering for free
on the edut bio info platform is
update your profile
right so
yes there are quite a few medical
doctors who take
our courses and we will be getting to
this question very very soon once i show
you the profiles here
so here as you see this is a complete
profile
of an individual and once you have
completed your profile and you have
attended one of our programs we
actually give out these certificates
and we will add them to your profile so
your profile can serve
as a cv or as a way uh
for you to display this or share this
with any of your peers
and help them get to know you better or
know where your skill sets are
right now as you see here semi has also
done
an independent project of her own so
that is also added to your profile so
this is why you need to update your
profile have a full name add a profile
photo and
complete your profile again for
researchers especially
you can also add your orcid ids you can
add your linkedin details as well as
your
facebook details or any other social
media that you would be
uh intending to add now once all of this
is over the second platform which we
will be utilizing
a lot to run the pipelines is the t
bio info platform as you see i'm signed
in here successfully
so to just give you an overview if you
click on one of these
i'm just showing you a demo pipeline you
can see that
here is a full set of an rna-seq
pipeline
so like this we will be going through
several different
pipelines with your mentors and elia
today would be giving you an
overview of this okay
nadjia so i will be showing you how to
create a profile right
at the end and
getting to the questions very very soon
and now as i was
talking about the pipeline so this is
the platform which you will have access
to
you cannot create access on the server d
by info platform
but once you register for the program
you will be getting access to this
platform
along with 5 tb of space in the cloud
to help you run the pipelines perform
analysis
and learn from it and the third platform
as
i have shown you earlier is the
omixlogic code playground
here you have different courses on
getting started with
r and python this is again
a platform which you can register for
free
i have put the link to the platform in
the chat box again
and we will also be utilizing this
platform extensively to learn from the
different resources
now before i go back to sharing the
slides
i am as i see there are a lot of
questions here in the chat box
we will be answering them right at the
end of the presentation so that we can
effectively answer everybody's question
i would also invite you to join our
communities
in linkedin uh atm could you kindly
check your
internet connection and adidas if you're
able to help aiden
uh with the audio issue you need to join
via zoom audio and also
uh sorry again and also invite you to
our facebook groups
so we are these groups we reach out to
our wider community and you are able to
interact with everyone else
who are part of this network now
let me get back quickly to the
presentation
and then pass it on to elia
okay so now i would like to introduce
you to what pine biotech does
so what we have been discussing here
today is a result of
hard work by an amazing team led by
company co-founders
dr alfred tober and dr leonid brodsky
dr alfred tober comes from a medical
background and has
extensive expertise in oncology
immunology
and biochemistry of inflammation and has
been recognized
internationally for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives
that support data science training and
applications in medicine
dr leonid brodsky is the director of the
turbo bioinformatics research center at
university of fifa
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics and over
the course of his career has developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team you see here are
experts in bioinformatics computer
science and training
and some of them will be presenting
today as well
the omits logic data science program is
designed to offer
an introduction to statistical analysis
and machine learning
and a broad overview of technologies and
project examples to learn about
and develop practical data science
skills using
user-friendly cloud technologies as well
as r
and python coding after completing the
program
you will gain experience with methods
for analysis of big data
and data wrangling essential skills for
bioinformaticians as well as those
interested in
other types of non-biology related
research
using data analysis the program
is designed for students starting from
the undergraduate level to faculty and
researchers from both biology and
clinician backgrounds
who can participate to learn more about
data science in biomedical research
in the upcoming omics logic program you
will have the opportunity to interact
and collaborate with an international
team of experts
specialized in the application of data
science to biological data sets
let me introduce you to the program
mentors
dr hardrich carr is our certified omix
logic trainer
and expert bioinformatician who will
guide the hands-on sessions and assist
participants with projects and analysis
during the program
her area of specialization is cancer
genomics and machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is our omics logic
project
mentor and an expert in big data
computational
analysis dr mazumdar has a phd in
computational biology and over
10 years of experience working with
industry and
academia eva brodsky is the prime market
co-founder
and ceo in his current role he has
extensive experience working together
with
industrial academic partners that are
applying
multi-omics integration and
bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications i will now
invite elia
to speak about the increasing
significance of data science and
biomedical research
and introduce you all to the types of
challenges we will be addressing
in this upcoming program thank you
and thank you everyone for joining today
uh as there are many questions in the
chat box i wanted to just ask everybody
to hold on with the questions until we
are done
and the reason for that is because i
think many of the questions will be
addressed in today's presentation
so before we start i also wanted to ask
everyone here a question
and i'm going to launch a poll where
there are three questions so the first
question is what country are you from
and uh we only have a few options here
but if you're
any other then please write which
country you're from in the chat box
the second question is what is your
level of education
high school bachelor's degree master's
degree phd or
other and what is your
area of interest and here you can select
multiple
things bioinformatics biotechnology
cell in molecular biology computer
science data science infectious diseases
oncology or others okay and
actually yes i see there's a fourth
question so what are you expecting to
get from this program
again you can select multiple things
here
and by the way just to let you know uh
this data
is also going to be one of our first
data sets that we will work with
in our data science training so we'll
see how to work with a data set that
comes from something like a chat box
try to analyze it understand what are
some major trends in all of the programs
that we run
so thank you for filling out the survey
and
uh we will keep this up just for a
couple more minutes for everybody to
have a chance to answer so we have about
uh half of you have answered already so
if you have not
yet please complete the survey
and again if you are from another
country that is not listed here
you can put out your answer write it out
in the chat box
okay so let's take a look okay see
canada pakistan uh
us okay there is a u.s
uh option in the poll so please use that
also
bolivia honduras uh uk
okay thank you puja pakistan
malaysia brazil japan
israel azerbaijan south africa
india finland argentina
okay excellent so looks like we cover
the whole world
world korea okay excellent thank you
everyone for
sharing that information saudi arabia
okay excellent thank you
okay so it looks like most of you have
answered
um ethiopia uh pakistan
okay great we will end the poll for now
mexico great thank you very much so
please complete in just one more minute
and we will end the poll
because what we want to talk about is
some
basic practical skills how do we load
data how do we
analyze the data what is data science
all about and how does it relate to
biomedical data
which this program is going to focus on
okay excellent thank you japan kenya
peru
mexico excellent thank you very much so
let's
end this poll
and we will share the results of this
poll
in just a little bit and in the meantime
let's go on to talk about
data science
okay so this program is going to be
focused
on biomedical data it's not just going
to be data science about
anything it's going to be specialized on
biomedical data
and because of that let's just think
about what is
the general idea behind data science so
data science
is the overlap between data
or informa information technologies
which deals with data storage
organization retrieval
data formats different ways to
manipulate that data
a statistical analysis or mathematical
analysis of data and being able to work
with that data extract meaningful
insights
hypothesis testing etc and some kind of
a specialization domain and so when we
talk about
biological data which is just one of the
types of data that you could specialize
in
when we talk about data science we end
up
having a lot of additional information
and considerations that come from
biological research
or the applications of data science to
understand
some particular type of an experiment or
data type for example clinical data
like the clinical trial data efficacy of
different drugs
etc so there is a heavy focus
on the type of data when we talk about
data science in general
when you join programs on data science
they
tend to be data agnostic but this
program is specifically for biomedical
data
and that means that we will use examples
from
biologically relevant sources which we
will describe
in actually our next session but today
let's talk about
what has happened in general with this
type of data
over the past several decades since the
time that
the human genome was sequenced and
assembled there has been
an explosion of this kind of data onyx
data that has changed the way that we
understand
different diseases and different types
of biological phenomena
that has been driven by high throughput
sequencing or
high throughput data in general it's the
ability to
automate data generation we can see
a clear example of that in the current
pandemic for example in the past
five pandemics the current pandemic has
been the one that has
accelerated the pace of generating real
time
or close to real time next generation
sequencing genomic data
for viral genomes at a tremendous speed
so you can see here a comparison that we
did
in the may of 2020 and
we see here about a five-fold increase
for the number of data sets that are
generated per
month about the novel coronavirus now
this seems to us today as almost trivial
we talk about different types of
mutations we talk about
the rate of infection we talk about all
of these data types
that previously have not been as
uh prominent and as easily understood so
the amount of data
the number of data sets coming in
per a period of time the variety of
this type of data is changing and
because of that
data science now is not just for data
scientists
data science is for anybody that deals
with biomedical research
or that has an interest in biological
research in general in fact
in biological papers in the publications
there are less and less publications
that do not deal
with a large quantity of data that has
to be processed and
analyzed and so the importance of data
science skills
is growing in this domain so one of the
major
types of data that we will be talking
about are omix
data types so what are omix data types
onyx data types are data generated
through high throughput
automated technologies for example next
generation sequencing but not
only for example one of the first data
types is phenomics phenomics
talks about external characteristics
of a sample that could be a tissue type
that could be cell morphology
it could be description of what that
sample
is and as we can generate a lot of this
data
it also needs to be processed and
analyzed
but the next type of data that probably
many of you are familiar with
is genomics genomics means variation at
the dna
level so it has to do with single
nucleotide variation
or multinucleotide variations like copy
number variation
and other variation in the dna code
another type of data is called
epigenomic data so epigenomic data is
data that can characterize
epigenetic regulation it can include
whole genome bisulfate sequencing data
that helps us study dna methylation
or it can help us characterize histone
modifications that help to
chromatin to be contracted or expanded
more accessible or less accessible and
interact in different ways with other
parts of the chromatin
we can also talk about the product of
epigenetic regulation which is
transcriptomic data or data that speaks
about gene and transcript expression
so levels of expression and alternative
splicing
so these are multi-omics data sets or
data sets that we will refer to in
general as
optics now let's come to the part of
the data science what can we do with
such data
so one important part that you need to
understand
about these data sets is that they speak
about
molecular detail at the subcellular
level
and the data that is being generated can
be used
to answer certain types of questions so
an important part here is to understand
how is this data generated
why is it generated what kinds of
questions could be asked of this data
and this is actually a very critical
part of a data scientist job
many people that come to a data science
problem they come to that problem as
engineers
and engineers have a very clear set of
rules about
inputs and outputs as opposed to that a
data scientist
is somebody that can think about the
problem and translate
a problem presented by let's say a
biologist into
a specific technical description and an
analysis
plan now that plan starts from
structuring the data which is what we'll
talk about today
but also being able to conceptually
explore the data
to understand what types of information
are there what kinds of variation need
to be adjusted
how to prepare that data for analysis
we'll also talk about
how such data could be used to ask
specific
questions and in many cases these
specific
questions are going to be based on
availability of a certain number of data
so that data could include three samples
and that means that we can only test
that small hypothesis
or it can include 3 000 samples and that
means that we will
face this problem of big data and so
we'll talk about
this trend of big data emerging in
multiple domains
including oncology neuroscience
agrotechnology
biotechnology pharmaceutical companies
use that data
and we'll talk about how to apply big
data analysis tools for
these large-scale data sets and
obviously we'll talk about how to
statistically
use appropriate methods to analyze data
including machine learning
that will allow us to explore data
structures
that will allow us to understand
similarity between many different types
of
data sources and also use classification
or predictive learning
to apply machine learning for a novel
data that is being generated
and importantly i think what we need to
go back to is also how to explain
what we have found in such analysis so
we'll talk a little bit about biological
interpretation
and how do we actually use all of these
insights that we have found
what are some practical applications for
those so what this program will do
is provide you with a complete roadmap
for data science
it's going to introduce you to a lot of
resources and we do not expect you to
complete all of them during the course
of this program
but we hope that you will take out of
this experience
and some understanding of how to find
data sets
explore and visualize them use them in
research
methods when you read a paper how to
interpret the research methods
and also gain insights and understanding
about some practical skills
and so as you can see this is kind of
like
navigating a maze because there's so
many different directions to go
you can spend all of your time on just
finding data sets or you can find all of
your time
on just learning how to code and we hope
to combine
elements of data science together to
provide you with a road map and we call
this road map
omixlogic so that is the logic behind
the analysis
the logic behind structuring your data
into some format that you can ask
questions and
interpret the answers that you are
getting
the program is going to be divided into
two parts
the first part is going to deal with
different omics data types
big data challenges how to clean load
and process data how to understand
what type of data and what kind of
information is included in that data
and getting some hands-on experience
with
doing coding in r and python just to
understand
what do those languages offer us it will
also introduce you to a number of
different
example projects and some processing
pipelines that you will probably not be
able to conduct on your own
because they deal with a huge number of
resources that need to be available at a
certain time so we'll use
that will leverage that big data
infrastructure to try and run
big data analysis the second part
we'll talk about statistical analysis
introduction to machine learning
and how to perform your basic analysis
and evaluate that analysis in terms of
accuracy and in terms of how
generally applicable it is for other
data sets so we'll talk about uh
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning we'll talk about model accuracy
and validation
and we'll also talk about the difference
between exploring
uh analyzing and actually getting
results with machine learning
now importantly as i mentioned this will
be applied to a number of different
project examples for example we'll talk
about
diagnostics and cancer biology we'll
talk about how to analyze single cell
data and tissue composition and what we
can learn from such data
and we'll also talk about the microbiome
and infectious diseases so we'll talk
about how can we analyze
specifically the data that was generated
to represent
species diversity or species richness
and how we can use such information to
ask questions
about different diseases or even
non-clinical conditions like
anxiety so as i mentioned a
an important part of all of these types
of omics data
is that they have to be processed so
essentially when we
talk about generating such digital data
we're talking about taking a sample and
applying
a specific technology that extracts
some portion of that sample of that
biological material
to produce a digital data describing
genomic variation epigenomic regulation
transcriptomics how genes are expressed
or even how
proteins or metabolized are expressed
and so that
processing of data is going to be a
major limitation for anyone that wants
to apply more advanced data science
methods
and in fact it is known that about
eighty percent of
a data scientist work is transforming
cleaning
and preparing data for analysis so we'll
spend some time
to talk about what are some of the
considerations around
using these big data analysis tools
in a logical way because ultimately
what we need is a map that combines
different methods together into what's
called bioinformatic pipelines
with explained methods so we'll talk
about what each one of these methods
means
and we'll talk about how to prepare them
into reproducible workflows
that you can share and uh understand
yourself but also share with others what
you have done
and we'll try to see how such processing
allows us to compare different
conditions
extracting only meaningful
differentially expressed genes
how we can use multivariate analysis of
big data when we have multiple features
and multiple types of differences that
we want to combine into a single
analysis
how to also think about the application
of we have found
if it's identification of protein
targets
single cell deconvolution or how do we
map
and represent complex relationships
using
our understanding of similarity between
different types of organisms
and genes so
at this point let me share the poll
results
okay and let's take a look briefly at
what we have in this uh group
so um it looks like for what country
are you from the majority here are from
other countries and so we also mentioned
many of the countries that many of you
put in the chat box so thank you for
that what is your level education looks
like the majority of the people here are
with a master's degree and the second
largest category is with a phd
for the area of interest the majority of
you are interested
in bioinformatics and the second
major group is in data science
and then we have uh
what are you expecting to get from this
program and the majority of you are
interested to learn about
data science or bioinformatics now the
reason
i am showing you these poll results
is because the poll results are
structured right i asked questions
and i got answers in the exact format
that i was asking
the answers that you wrote in the chat
as we were reading them it's very hard
to get a sense
of how many are for example from
pakistan or from finland or from
argentina or from korea
i have to go back and i have to analyze
what i have in the chat box also
assuming that many of you put things
in variation somebody used a capital
letter pakistan somebody used a lower
level
pakistan right so there's some
processing that has to be done
with this unstructured data so that's
why
in the context of this program let's
think of this poll
as an experiment we need to understand
the experiment design so when i asked
you these questions
i had something in mind i wanted to
understand some specific question
now another person can look at the data
that i have that i have collected and
maybe somebody else's data that they
collected
and they will look at how this data is
organized and what the numbers show
and they will try to make inference they
will try to understand
what that means in general about some
population of people
so when we think about how these data
sets are generated we have to keep that
in mind
we have to see that what we are dealing
with
is data that was produced by design
and so when that data was collected
we'll talk about how
it is collected what are the different
mechanisms of
generating the actual digital data that
we deal with
then it has to be cleaned for example if
i look at
the category called other do i keep it
do i try to structure it
do i eliminate it from my data set i
need to create
tiny data or data that is ready for
analysis
and i also need to understand how this
data
represents the experimental conditions
or
groups of samples that i have okay so
we'll talk about
exploratory data analysis where
important things are visualization
and data mining or visual visually
trying to look at my data
and seeing what's in it or using some
additional methods that help me find
more nuanced patterns that i might not
be able to spot easily with my eyes
but nevertheless they represent some
trend some pattern
and not noise they're not random finally
we'll talk about data analysis
so an important consideration in data
analysis is
selecting out of many statistical tests
and statistical models
how do i actually find the right one
knowing what my data represents
and knowing what kind of result i am
trying to get out of my
data analysis process and how do i
share the results of the model by
providing summary statistics
and knowing what these summary
statistical measurements mean
finally we'll talk about inference how
do we take what we have learned
and interpret it to represent a larger
trend
that we would like to generalize so in
many cases
we do not have the ability to sample
all of the people in the population or
all of the samples that represent some
kind of a condition
we take a sample and that sample will be
used
to generalize our understanding and that
has to do with
how robust our analysis is based on
collected data
selected model and the results of
statistical analysis
okay so at this point i want to just
pause
and make sure that we address any
questions that you might have so far
so i saw a couple of questions here and
let me briefly address them
so some of the questions were about
registration
i hope that we answered those some of
you answered about how all of
it asked about how all of these
resources are going to be utilized i
hope that we are starting to answer this
and i'll conclude our session today
with some more information about it
another question
uh um about this
uh paid course of the free webinar so
again the way that this uh
will work is you will join sessions like
today
we will have some assignments that we
will do together we'll we'll get to that
in just a second you will see what that
looks like
and so if you want to participate in the
full program you have to benefit from
both but if you don't have the time
and you don't want to spend the time to
come in
at something at a session like this you
can also
join the much more accessible and
affordable
asynchronous courses and beeps that will
share the links
so once you register you will see
what those include and i think that will
also explain how is this course
different from coursera
and edx so a lot of the focus here will
be on
biomedical application of data science
and we will do a lot of
practical analysis of data and source
uh kind of evaluation of different
sources of data so that you can actually
ask
biologically relevant research questions
of that data
in the context of the program so it's a
lot more personalized and a lot more
practical i would say
then let's say coursera or something
like that
okay can the results obtained be used
for
publishing publishing is
not an easy challenge i think that many
of us coming from research background
you will will know that a typical
research
article takes maybe between six months
to a year maybe even more
there's a reason why phds take a long
time
uh after you've gained that experience i
think it becomes a little bit easier
but no one will likely say that
publishing is
easy so we will be able to go through
the process of exploring different
sources of data
using big data analysis tools data
science
in r and python and biological
interpretation
to in the end get some results those
results could eventually be turned into
a publication but it's likely going to
be
taking longer than just the one month
program that we're talking about now
we do have a research fellowship program
that is more
for those people that already have the
basic skills but would like to work
on a research project with a group of
other research fellows that we have
and with our mentors so thank you for
your questions
beeps will add some more answers in the
chat
and some links and for us to get
most out of this session let's go on
and get to some practical examples of
what we will do
in the program okay so if you do have
any other questions
you can continue posting them in the
chat box and beep say if you could
please share the links again for those
that have joined recently
of how to register how to get access to
the educational portal
how to get access to the coding and to
look at the platform
that we will use okay
so as i mentioned the first problem
is that we will be dealing with
unstructured data as a general trend
about 80 of the data that is being
generated today
is unstructured that means that there
was no model for this data this data is
not like a survey that had specific
questions it wasn't in a in a structured
format
and if you want to think about how the
data in biomedical research is
unstructured you can think of
a vial of blood so as you can see right
here right so somebody collected blood
and then that blood had to be turned
into
genomic sequences so the way that works
is that there is a library to extract
specific types of dna portions
out of the blood and so there's a whole
biological process in the lab that's
being done for that
and then those pieces of dna those
fragments of dna that you can see right
here
are shattered and sequenced and when
they are sequenced
we are essentially dealing with a lot of
short dna sequences
and one of the major challenge is to
work with that
unstructured data and structure it right
and so as i mentioned about 80 of
your work as a data scientist or a data
engineer
is to be able to understand how the data
was generated
and turn it into a structured format and
that includes
accessing and loading the data cleaning
it
understanding what it means and then
preparing that data for
analysis so we will look at
how to apply different types of
processing
pipelines to make this into a structured
data set
okay and lydia is asking here i have
rnac data can i work on my research in
this course yes
so if you already have some research
data that you would like to analyze
and make sense of learning about the
different principles of analysis
this is exactly the type of a program
that you would want to join
now the other type of data is structured
data
and structured data as you can see right
here includes
a organization structure right so this
means that we have here a table of
expression
in this table of expression we have
different types
of genes represented by a
gene id and different types of cell
lines
that also have a different class and
inside this table of expression we see
the levels of
expression right so just a question for
all of you
how many genes are there in
the human genome approximately
again for those of you that don't have a
data set we will actually show you how
to find some data set
all right excellent so we have here some
answers sharif perna
uh kabia okay twenty five thousand
thirty
thousand thirty two thousand twenty
thousand
all right excellent so yes you know your
stuff so
it is approximately twenty five 000
genes
however as you can see from
the answers that people are providing
here there's actually
a variation and the reason for that is
because
the human genome that was sequenced
almost uh 60 70
years ago is still being studied
for what do we mean when we say a gene
right and so a gene sequence
is a fluid concept that continues to be
expanded and so the number of genes that
are being discovered is also growing
and so i think that's one of the things
that we need to remember
is that we will deal with data that
continuously
is updated in terms of our biological
understanding
in terms of the number of elements that
we're going to be looking at
and now if you think about each gene
representing
multiple transcripts or multiple types
of the ways that exons are spliced
together
you will see that we can easily get to
anywhere between
20 000 or maybe even 10 000 in a cell
line
that is very specialized all the way to
about 60 000 for some cases
if we include different transcripts so
for each sample
we're dealing with a very large number
of
data points or features that we're going
to be dealing with
now as we structure the data we need to
think of
several different ways that we can
organize
this data in a particular
structure and in the case of our
language
which is something that we will try to
use today there are several different
ways that we can store this information
for example we can use what's called a
vector
a vector is a one-dimensional array that
is used to store a collection
of data in the same mode for example you
can have
a number of a list of numbers
okay and that could be a vector um
there are numeric vectors there are
complex vectors there are logical
vectors
and there are character vectors or text
strings so different modes for vectors
there are also matrices you can see here
matrix a matrix is like a table
but it is only used to store
data of the same mode so if you have all
numbers
and they are just the cells over here so
just the numbers here could be turned
into a matrix so you have to remove all
of these
strings right here and that could be
turned
in and stored in a matrix
multiple matrixes or matrices together
could form an array and so an array
could be
multiple tables like this
you can also have factors so these could
be categorical
variables designed to group the
components of another vector with the
same size
so if you look at this table right here
who can tell me
where is a factor
where could i create a factor
for this matrix right here
okay excellent thank you vaishu
the class row right here if i take these
i can turn them into factors because
essentially you can see that they are
repeating
and they represent the type of sample
that i'm dealing with
okay and so this could be a
this could be factors these could be
names of my samples these could be names
of my features
and this is a matrix all together this
could be
a data frame or essentially a table
okay so let's remain let's remember
these definitions as we will go in
today's
practical part of today's session
okay and for prarna she was asking to
repeat about factors
so again factors are uh you can see here
right in this data frame or in this
table
we have names of genes we have names
of our samples but the samples fall into
specific categories in this case this we
just see here one category
luminal cells and so the factors
let's say i have condition and control
and i have
three samples in condition three samples
in control if i want to ask
what factors do i have in my table i
would say two factors condition and
control
how many of each one three and three
okay so those are factors
if you think about your experiment
design when you're designing your
experiment you want to compare something
you design those by experiment factors
okay now the other important part of
working with this structured data once
it is prepared
you want to analyze the data for
how it represents what you know about
the data
and how that data is generated okay
there are two
considerations here the first one let's
talk about
a biological experiment as we said we
have three
data sets or three samples in our
condition
and three samples in our control if i
take
two samples from the condition or two
samples
from the control so two samples of the
same kind
i need to know that i can accurately
represent that condition
with those samples and the way to
compare them is they can use
a model to assume
that they are correlated so if they are
correlated if the gene expression values
are correlated
i know that i can use them to represent
that condition
if they are not correlated i know that
there's some other pattern
and i might be forcing my model onto the
data
the other part of it is that this type
of a comparison
is not going to provide me with the
right kind of values
if it does not follow some assumptions
about the data and so another
consideration here
is what's called the distribution or
data or how many
of each one of my numbers fall into a
bin based on some kind of a distribution
of the full data set okay and so we'll
talk a lot about these so don't be
overwhelmed right now with all these
considerations if this is completely new
to you
this is something that we'll deal with
in detail throughout the program so
we first structure the data we have to
put it in
a right object and once we have that
object
we also need to understand the
properties of that object
that include some kind of exploration of
the data characteristics and so here
we'll talk about some of the ways to
prepare the data
for analysis a lot of that
has to do with our understanding of the
biology behind what the data was created
for
and how and so a lot of the methods that
you will see will include
considerations around thresholds and
around an understanding of what's the
bulk or the noise maybe
and what is the specific signal or what
are we actually trying to compare
so when we talk about biological data it
is known
that biological data does not follow a
normal distribution
in a raw format it also represents a lot
of noise
that biologically is meaningful but also
can introduce a lot of noise into our
comparative model or our
contrasts but also we know that there
are specific
technical things that we need to
understand about the process of
generating the digital data
and so we'll talk about how to address
those as well
finally we'll talk about how to present
our analysis in a meaningful way so
we'll talk about things like
heat maps scatter plots principle
component analysis et cetera and we'll
talk about
what is the meaning of what we are
seeing how do we interpret what we are
seeing
and how do we make sure that what we are
presenting if we want to share our
results
looks meaningful to somebody that is
going to be looking at it from
a technical perspective that is correct
but also from a biological perspective
that
it immediately is clear what you're
trying to say
finally we'll talk about data mining and
classification and so
here we have a lot of different examples
of these methods and i want to ask you a
question
who can point out one example here
of classification so just
one example of a classification method
again you can type your answers into the
chat box so
is there a classification method okay
okay so so some people are mentioning
clustering k-means clustering decision
trees hierarchical clustering
okay clustering all right so again
classification is not clustering
clustering helps us understand
groups of samples in our data
and classification is used to predict
the class
based on learning so we'll talk about
this in greater detail but i'm glad to
see that
there are some you know some people know
maybe more about this than others but
this is an important
way to think about our different types
of methods and when we think about these
methods
we need to understand what are some of
the considerations for example
why do we not use linear discriminatory
analysis
for complex data or what is the
difference between
random forest and decision trees
or how can we think about hierarchical
clustering
and decision trees how are they similar
and how are they
not similar right so we'll talk about
all of these different aspects of
machine learning data mining
classification and we'll think about how
to also combine these methods together
so that we can use them effectively now
in these sessions we'll not only go
through slides and talk about different
hypotheticals right
what we'll do is we'll actually go
through very practical examples
so let's go and do a little example
together
so if you could go with me to code
onyxlogic.com
hopefully all of you have already signed
up there
and this is going to be a free
course so you don't have to worry about
paying anything so this is a completely
free resource
what we'll do is we'll do a very quick
example
of how to load data in r and understand
what is the data set that we are dealing
with
okay so if you go to code.omicslogic.com
please let me know once you are logged
in
okay so it is code omixlogic.com
okay so once you are here and you're
logged in
you can see that i'm logged in you go
to courses okay so please let me know
once you're inside and you see the
courses
what we will be going through in this
session
is an example over here for
introduction to data science and we'll
just do one quick example from r
okay so please come with me to this
first lesson how to load data and check
for variable data
and what you should see on your screen
is something like this so please
put number one in the chat box once you
see what i see here on the screen
all right thank you vaishun sharif all
right right
right so we have about 70 people here on
the call so if you
uh want to put number one i'll give it a
couple of minutes
um and in the meantime i'll tell you
just
a little bit of an introduction to data
types and data structures in r
just to kind of refresh everybody's
memory
so even if you have completed we'll do
something a little bit different from
exactly what this lesson does
so please stay with us najiha okay so
to make the most out of using our
language
you need a strong understanding of the
basic data types and data structures
and how to operate them so what you can
do with them how to use them effectively
etc
data structures are very important to
understand because
these are the objects that you will
manipulate on a daily basis
in r dealing with object conversions is
one of the most common sources of
frustration for beginners
in fact i would say one of the major
challenges that many people face
is how do you actually get a data set
into something that you can work with
so a lot of tutorials start with you
know let's do one plus one or something
like this right but here we want to deal
with biomedical data we need to
load and understand what's in it so r
has six basic data types
character numeric which could be real or
decimal
integer logical or complex
so elements of these data types may be
combined to form data structures
for example atomic vectors so when we
call a vector atomic
we mean that the vector only holds data
of a single data type
so here are some examples of atomic
character vectors numeric vectors
integer vectors etcetera
a character could be a numeric could be
2
and 15.5 integer could be 2l
okay the l tells r to store this as an
integer
logical which is true or false and
complex for example one plus four
i okay so those are vectors
and also r has many functions to examine
features of vectors
and other objects for example you can
use the functions
class type of length and attributes
okay so let's think about how we can
learn about this in this example okay so
you will see
understand the problem you can see that
we can import data directly
here and let's look at what is the basic
code
so the basic code here is to load a
table
where you need to include a path for
that table
and you need to also specify some things
about the tables you need to know what
the table is like for example it could
be
a tab separated table you would use
a slash t it could be a csv so it could
be a comma separated so you would
include a comma here and it could either
include or not include a header
right so as we saw in our example here
we can have a table and that table can
contain some information
in this first line that's called the
header so we can specify that right here
and obviously then we can print what we
find
in our data so let's go to next and
we'll see
a little code block that we can use
together okay so
here you'll see the first code block
what it includes is a function called
read table
and because we're going to use a table
we need to put
here a link to a txt file
so if you right click right here on this
link
you can use copy link
and then replace the path
so you can see we're using here
biologically height data set
we'll keep header as true separator is
tab delimited
and you can just click on run
so because we are printing this object
it is going to tell us what this object
contains
and you can see that this is a table
there's an id
specimen one two three and four there's
the type of specimen
specimen flower tree and bird and there
are some numbers
in here okay now
let's use the function class
okay so what is the class of what we
have
loaded it is a table right so it's a
data frame okay
so now we have different types of
attributes
inside this data frame and so here we
can use type of
and say again df and do run
and you can see that the first one
is list right so because it's going to
look right here
for a list okay
so and and so forth right so you can
actually
start playing around with this data set
because you have
loaded into a data frame
okay so this is just a very brief
example
you can also practice on how to do this
with excel
or a csv file and some other
biological data sets the key point here
is to understand how to load a data set
and also how to explore what type of
data have you loaded
any questions about this
all right great so i hope that this was
clear right
we have some data that we can look and
additional types of analyses in r
and in python will go through a lot of
the same methods
header true okay so just to explain
again what is header equals true
yes so this is a free resource there's a
lot of free coding lessons here you can
go ahead and explore them some of them
have also paid lessons
but if you join the program you will see
how it's all combined
and it works best when somebody's
guiding you through this because not
everything could be explained easily
in an online tutorial okay
yes the path should be in quotes what is
the header
the header is the first line the first
line is not the data itself
you're just telling the uh
you're just specifying that this is
going to be used as
names of samples and are not to be
included in the actual analysis
all right now as i mentioned there are a
lot more courses like this that we will
go through
in this whole tutorial and the objective
of this program
is to try and piece together this puzzle
of different types of projects different
types of
data types and sources and different
types of
practical analysis techniques to help
guide you from where you are at a very
beginner level or you are more advanced
to actually make
uh progress and gain experience with
analysis
of data okay and rudina if you can if
you're getting an
error cannot open the connection maybe
it's because too many people are doing
this at the same time just reload the
page
okay so combined together we will use
these three different resources
educational training materials which you
can get
access to online without the whole
this session like we're doing it
interactively
you can gain access to a number of
different educational courses
you will have a platform for big data
analysis
you will also have coding exercises and
together
you will really gain a perspective of
how
data science can help you explore
different type of data
that are genomic transcriptomic
metagenomic
metabolomic proteomic etc to explore
variation and make biological
interpretation now as i mentioned
an important part of that is being able
to reproduce workflows that others have
done
so you will see how we will go through
the different publications that explain
this data
and explain the method of analysis and
turn that
into a tutorial for you so we will look
at examples of sequence alignment
rna sequencing evolutionary analysis
machine learning variant calling and
structure analysis
all for you to make the most out of the
different
examples so that you can use this in the
context of what you are interested in
now what we saw today is just an example
of an online solution that we will use
to make sure that everybody's on the
same page but we will also introduce you
to our studio and jupiter notebooks and
python
so that you can take what you learn and
use it on your own computer
so for those of you that are new to this
completely
um you can actually watch this little
video
that will tell you how to install
rstudio on your computer
and so in the first few lessons we're
going to be using
are a little bit more but in as we go
more into the machine learning part of
it we will also start using python
okay so here you will see how to in this
video that i
share you will see a basic explanation
of how to install rstudio on your
computer
and then also set up some basic things
like your working directory
or installing different packages now the
benefit of
what we are going to be doing in this
program is that we are going to be
combining all of these different
elements together
to help you make the most out of
different types of tools
and also understand them in the context
of
specific examples so all the data sets
all the
different packages and functions that
you will need are pre-installed
on this online solution ultimately
you will gain experience on
visualization statistical analysis
and ways to interpret the data that you
have
and so here we will see examples like
principal component analysis
visualization
and other things and so the main
objective here as you can see on the
side
is to understand the problem learn the
code
learn to modify the outputs and then
modify
settings and apply to the data and
hopefully by that time we will do a
session tomorrow
or not tomorrow in our next session
where you will see
how to find data sets so if you have a
data set we'll talk about processing
if you don't have a data set we'll show
you how to find data sets that you can
work with
and the next session is going to be on
january 14th same
thank you so the project
part of this program is very important
and we hope that all of you
will be able to get through some of the
basic things you can see here we track
the um the activity of all of the users
so that you can get a sense of where you
are
and we track these three different
things utilization of the platform
completion of courses and how you
complete coding challenges
and you will first get an introduction
to some basics
and then you'll be able to apply what
you have learned to a project so we hope
that you will come out of this program
with a project of your own to get you
started
we also have a number of project
examples that we
have prepared following some publicly
available data sets that you can find on
ncbi for example
one of these will be modeling cancer
precision medicine
where we take a publication on different
breast cancer cell lines
and look at how to analyze such data to
understand the differences between these
cell lines
and in each one of these data sets
we will go through the publication and
we look at some keywords
of what you will actually learn here you
can see mentioned
in yellow the conceptual
ideas like molecular profiles or
molecular pathobiology
and also the specific methods like
support vector machines random forest
mutation gene and isoform expression etc
so
hopefully after this session or after
this program
you will be able to easily read through
the publication
understand all of the terminology but
also learn how to interpret these visual
abstracts so that you can take this on
with you to your own
independent project now we've prepared a
number of different examples they range
from deadly mutations in ebola virus to
the
origins and pathogenesis of the novel
coronavirus
infection and treatment of tuberculosis
insect cell lines contamination
and production of biologics so we have a
lot of different examples that you can
start with
to get you ahead so that you don't have
to go from
very basic kind of trying to understand
why the data was generated etc so at the
end
you will get a certificate of completion
for the full program
and you'll be able to also get
individual certificates for
courses and again we have
you know thousands of participants that
have joined from many different
backgrounds
including people that have postdoc
positions and research positions
at different clinically relevant
research positions that you can actually
apply this
in the context of biomedical research
and many of the participants actually
that have joined and completed these
previous
programs have been able to compare
this program to some other alternatives
on edx and coursera
and so we have a blog post by one of our
participants who works as a
bioinformatician
as a genetic testing company called
atlas
um how this is different from some of
the other programs out there i know that
some of you have asked
and i thought that maybe it would be
useful so
if you could share the link to that blog
post as well
so again what we will study in the first
part of this program
is how to deal with data learn how to
load it learn how to manipulate it and
explore it
in the second part of the program we
will learn about statistical analysis
machine learning
and how to do this in the context of
specific projects
after the basic training you will be
introduced
to projects and data sets that you can
find online
on your own or use your own data sets to
do the analysis as you
have learned in the program okay
so that was the end of this presentation
thank you again for bearing with me i
know it was a little bit longer than
expected
but at this point if any of you have any
questions i would be happy to answer
those
we also have here with us vipsa biswas
who's our community manager and if you
have any questions about registration
payment access to different resources
updating your profile
etc please reach out to her it is
marketing at pine.bio we have our
project
mentor dr mohit mizunder who is going to
be helping those of you that decide to
go on and work on
an independent research project so you
can reach him
at mohit at pine dot bio
and we will also have dr harpreet ka or
starting from our next session her
email is support at pine.bio if you have
any technical questions about
bioinformatics
r packages python loading your data
getting a specific type of visualization
or an error resolved
please email her as well uh elia
i do have a few questions here uh to
address
uh one that i would want to address is
the question whether
uh so i got this question from a lot of
participants attending today that they
may not be able to make
time for the sessions which start at 9
00 a.m cst
so in case you are not able to make time
at 9 am cst due to other obligations
which you may have
we always record all of our sessions so
if you are
intending to attend the program it is
going to be a one month
uh program which is spaced out and i
will again be sending the schedule for
the program
with everyone so we will record everyday
session
so you can watch that video later and
that video will remain with you because
we upload it to a private playlist on
youtube and share it with only the
participants who are attending the
program
so you will have exclusive access to
that throughout the
range of this program and beyond that
and in case you also need mentor support
as i already mentioned
you can actually ask for mentor support
who will be
able to help you with any questions that
you have
uh during the session and
here is a question elia uh which i think
uh we should answer
like is multi-omics used exclusively for
research purposes or is it able to be
used commercially amongst the medical
community
yeah so i would just mention about that
that the platform that we're going to be
using here
is a platform that is used by many
different
medical researchers as you know research
in the omics era is becoming more and
more
commercially viable so analyzing data
sets from
transcriptomic genomic epigenomic
regulation data
together about the same phenomena is
extremely powerful because you have
the additional validation of an
independent source of data
about the same probably messy and
noisy situation so multinomics data sets
are generated
in a biomedical research you know
translational research context
i would say that it is very rarely
generated in actual clinical setting
because
clinical refers to making a specific
decision about it or maybe having a
a payment code associated with that
analysis and it's not there yet but it's
definitely moving in that direction now
in terms of using the multilinx analysis
platform
we have a lot of uh you know regulatory
oversight over the platform hosting and
data management
so if you are interested in analyzing
proprietary data of clinical
significance
you can get a research account which
will provide you with that security as
well
yes anybody has any other questions
you can always reach out to me marketing
at pine dot buyer
and i just wanted to uh let everybody
know that
uh the discount code is supposed to end
by today
so there is a 20 discount that we had
been offering so
you can check your emails for that code
if you are interested
and if you are joining if you have any
other questions please reach out to me
marketing at find.bio and i will be able
to assist you with any queries
even uh related to your research
fellowship program
or the research license for the t
bioinfo server or any other questions
that you may have regarding projects
as well as the data science program and
thank you again for joining and thank
you elia
uh for taking us through this lecture
today
so we hope to see you in the next
session
okay great thank you everyone and
looking forward to our next session
january 14th